>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington DC.
>> But also, as you may know, this program
is part of a series of webinars connected
with the Library's exhibition, Echo's of the
Great War, American Experiences of World War I,
which is on view here through January, 2019.
Today's presentation will last
approximately 30 minutes, with time after that
for our presenter to answer questions.
You can communicate with me and with
Katherine Blood, our presenter by the Chadwell,
and unfortunately it looks like not with
your [inaudible], as I said before we began,
you're welcome to send me a
note and I'll share it out.
I'll collect questions as well for
Katherine on the chat and we'll share them
with her at the end of the session.
So, please think about what you'd like
to ask her as the session goes on.
We will post the recording of this presentation
to the Library's website once it
has been captioned, and with that,
I will introduce Katherine, so today's
presenter is curator Katherine Blood,
who works with the Library's world class
collection of artists prints, drawings,
and posters in its Prints
and Photographs Division.
And Katherine, that makes you the presenter now.
Her exhibition and publications
projects have specialized in modern
to contemporary graphic art by
American, Hispanic and Japanese artists.
Today's webinar is based on a public gallery
talk that Katherine gave earlier this year
as part of our programing
for the Echoes exhibit.
Katherine, thank you so much
for leading today's webinar.
>> Thank you, Naomi and to
everyone joining us today.
As Naomi mentioned, today's discussion is based
on a gallery talk I gave earlier this year
focusing on one particular World War I drawing
by artist, Joseph Pennell, and we'll
be looking closely at this in a minute,
but let's start by thinking a little bit
about visual communication at the time.
When the U.S. entered the war on April 6, 1917,
there was a thriving visual
culture in full swing.
For example, images were circulating widely
in illustrated magazines and newspapers
and photography was well
established by this time with more
and more people taking pictures
with their own personal cameras.
But World War I marked another notable leap
forward in the history of visual communication,
and this was thanks in large part to the
extraordinary proliferation of war posters
and other images made by some of the best
artists of the day, and also the volume
at which they were produced and
ways they were disseminated.
On screen are some examples from
the Library's extensive collection
and you can see they were tilted
at getting audiences to feel,
respond and act or participate in various ways.
And while many of the images appeal to
notions of patriotism, honor and courage,
others tap into fear and hatred of the enemy.
Some of the major recurring
themes include recruitment,
like the first several examples
here in the top row.
Also, bond drives to raise funds in support of
the war, home front service and various forms
of troop support from knitting to donating
books for soldier's camp libraries.
That's one of my favorites in the second row,
the second one in, by Charles Buckles Falls.
And you can explore over 1,900 World War
I posters in the Library's online catalog
and we'll show you where you can search
for and study them in a little while.
Everything you'll see on screen today,
with one exception that I'll point out,
comes from the Library's collection
of original artist's prints,
posters, drawings and photographs.
Today we're going to be taking a deep
look at an indelible and famous artwork
by American artist, Joseph Pennell.
The Library of Congress is fortunate to
preserve both Pennell's concept drawing,
which we see on the left, and his
related Liberty Bond poster of which
over 500,000 copies were printed in 1918.
We'll also take a look at some of the
broader context and forces that came together
in launching a virtual armada
of compelling wartime posters,
including this well-known example.
As a gateway for that discussion,
here's how the drawing was presented
in the physical exhibition,
the Echoes exhibition,
where it hung alongside some excellent company.
That's Cheryl Regan gazing up at the artwork.
She's our Echoes Exhibit Director, and let me
also credit our lead curators for that show,
Ryan Reft and Sara Conway Lance [phonetic] who
worked with a large team, including myself.
If you look at the wall behind Cheryl,
you may spot some familiar faces,
and perhaps this one in particular.
James Montgomery Flagg's, "I want you for U.S.
Army" with his truly iconic Uncle Sam based,
according to the artist, on his own face.
Both Pennell and Flagg were among the
many artists to contribute their work
for the division of pictorial publicity
within Woodrow Wilson's Committee
on Public Information.
It was this man, George Creel,
who headed the committee.
He was a journalist and politician who
believed that art could play a crucial role
in winning the hearts and minds of the American
public, to build support behind the war.
And his idea was that whereas people might miss
or bypass text or films or community meetings,
even the most indifferent
eye, and that's his phrase,
even the most indifferent eye could not
fail to encounter posters and billboards.
In his project memoir called, "How we advertised
in American," Creel stressed that he was
after no less than the very best work
by the best artists and in his words,
"Posters into which the masters of the pen
and brush have poured heart
and soul, as well as genius."
And he continues, "Looking the field
over, we decided upon Charles Dana Gibson
as the man best fitted to
lead the army of artists."
I like that he thought of them as an army.
"And on April 17, 1917, this splendid
American entered the service as a volunteer."
So that would have been just a little over a
week after America entered the war on April 6.
And Creel made a very savvy choice
when he tapped Charles Dana Gibson
to run the committee's Division
of Pictorial Publicity.
Gibson was a very popular leading
and well-connected illustrator,
celebrated for his creation of the Gibson Girl,
and you can see a classic
example of that, top left.
As president of the Society of American
Illustrators, Gibson was well placed
to rally the troops, the artists troops, and
when he famously urged his fellow artists
to draw till it hurts, in support of
the war, he was talking to such peers
as James Montgomery Flagg,
Howard Chandler Christy,
Edward Penfield, Joseph Pennell and many others.
By January of 1918, Gibson reported that
the artists were meeting every Friday
at their New York headquarters on 5th
Avenue to review projects submitted
by different government departments.
Afterwards, Gibson said they adjourned
to Key's Chop House for dinner.
The ranks swelled to 300
volunteer artists who produced more
than 1,400 designs including some 700 posters
that were spread throughout the country,
and they were everywhere, on the streets,
in offices, schools, theaters, libraries,
street cars, shop windows
and other public spaces.
So, in the flow of your daily life, you would
have inevitably encountered these images.
And we have some great period photo
documentation of the posters in situ,
like the image we were just looking
at of the billboard on the street
and the scene from a naval recruiting office.
And just look at all of the posters
plastered on the surrounding walls.
Many of these are represented in the Library
as collection of original World War I posters
and if you'll just take a second and kind of
memorize those back walls and hold those images
in your mind, I'll show you a few closer color
images of the posters from our collection,
including Howard Chandler Christy's classic
GI, "Wish I were a man, I'd join the Navy."
When Pennell joined the Division of
Pictorial Publicity as an associated chairman,
he was about 60 years old, so a mature,
successful artist, who like Gibson and Flagg,
had helped to find what would be known
as the golden age of illustration.
From the 1880's to the 1920's and this
is square during Pennell's active years.
He was born in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania in
1857 and he trained at the Pennsylvania Academy
of Fine Arts, and the Pennsylvania
School of Industrial Art.
He later taught at the National
Academy of Design
and the Art Students League in New York City.
Pennell died in Brooklyn, New York in 1926.
This pictorials' style portrait shows
him in 1922 when he was in his mid-60's.
During his long career, Pennell gained acclaim
for his work as an illustrator and print maker.
He published treatises about
drawing and print making
and taught, lectured and exhibited widely.
He was a prolific illustrator of journal
articles and books by the likes of Henry James,
Washington Irving and William Dean Howells.
On screen is one of the drawings he made
for Henry James' 1909 book, Italian Hours.
Pennell and his journalist wife, Elizabeth
Robbins Pennell often collaborated together.
She would do the writing and he would
illustrate and they were also devotees,
friends and biographers of
James McNeill Whistler.
Early on, as you can see in this drawing,
Pennell's work shows the
clear influence of Whistler.
This is an early portrait drawing by
Pennell of his wife in Rome in 1885.
But Pennell liked to live in high
rise apartments with sweeping views
where Pennell could make drawings
like the delicate watercolor you see
here called the, Out of my London Window.
Pennell is also one of the early
artists to depict skyscrapers
as fine art subjects beginning around 1904, and
here's his drawing of the Flat Iron building
in 1908, only six years after it was built.
This opalescent sunset watercolor
on the right shows the stunning view
from their Brooklyn home.
They made the move from Philadelphia
to Brooklyn in 1921.
And you may be able to see a bit
sketchily in the distance on the left,
there's the Statue of Liberty under the clouds.
Pennell is often called the
dean of American print making
and he was a skillful accomplished lithographer
and etcher, who had a lifelong fascination
with industrial subjects, a theme
he called the Wonder of Work.
And by this he meant pictures
of architecture, engineering,
construction, all kinds of industry.
He found these subjects profoundly compelling
and became gifted at presenting them
as picturesque, an idea that was traditionally
associated with artist renderings with nature,
and beautiful landscapes
rather than urban cityscapes.
So, we see a Chicago skyline, the standard oil
building in New York, and a dramatic rendering
of a grain elevator in Hamburg, Germany.
This lithograph is from Pennell's celebrated
series documenting the construction
of the Panama Canal.
And images of people are somewhat rare
in his work, and usually in service
to the larger composition to
indicate scale or bustling activity.
Though Pennell considered this grouping
of workers particularly decorative.
It was based on an eye witness moment.
When the Panama Pacific International Exhibition
was mounted in 1915 to celebrate the opening
of the Panama Canal, Pennell shared a
juried exhibition of over 2,000 prints
and he had a room dedicated
to some 150 of his own.
And here he is looking very
intrepid at the construction site
and that little sign is basically saying
that you walk here at your own peril.
And here are a couple more
images showing Pennell in action.
These were both taken at the
Chicago Stockyards around 1918.
One shows Pennell surrounded by a
crowd near what looks like a warehouse
and the other he's sitting on the balcony and he
seems to have had a sketchbook with him always,
many portraits of him showing
him clutching a sketchbook.
Our collection also has many
examples of his sketchbooks.
By the time Pennell came to the
Division of Pictorial Publicity in 1917,
he had already built strong
credentials and a solid body
of artworks documenting war
preparation in England,
which was his home base with
his wife for many years.
On screen from left to right are lithographs
from his series of war work in England,
first in England, then in America.
It's fascinating to know that Pennell was raised
as a Quaker and was personally opposed to war,
but for his ongoing exploration
of his wonder of work theme,
the chance to document war
preparation was the opportunity
of a lifetime, it was irresistible to him.
With government backing in both England and
America, Pennell was granted special access
to sensitive sites including
shipyards and ammunition factories.
And here's a close-up detail of the
Censor Stamp from the [inaudible]
of Pennell's submarine in drydock.
The stamp is on the left showing
that the artwork had passed scrutiny
by the Philadelphia Navy yard
sensor on November 7, 1917,
and that Pennell was not giving away any
state secrets by distributing this image.
Pennell was vocal, he made no bones
about the tension between a boring war
and being enthralled by its
technology and scale.
Pennell's wartime artworks were exhibited at
multiple venues including the Brooklyn Museum
in 1917, where the accompanying catalog
boasted introductions by H.G Wells and Pennell.
And here are quotes from both.
To me, I think Wells really reflected the work
well and understood what Pennell was after.
The full quote is on screen, but I'll just
read the last bit, this is on the right.
"He gives us the splendors and immensities
of forge and gun-pit, furnace and mine-shaft.
He shows you how great they
are and how terrible."
And for his part, Pennell's quote on
the left expresses his ambivalence.
He wrote, "It is the working of the great
machinery and the great mills which I find
so inspiring, so impressive, and if only the
engines turned out were engines of peace,
how much better would the world be?"
Now, this is the first of two
Liberty-Loan posters Pennell designed.
This one was for the third Liberty-Loan,
the Washington Post and the New York Times
on March 10, 1918 both published articles
that reported a planned 9 million posters were
to be designed and distributed by various
artists and they would be distributed
in the U.S., Hawaii, Alaska, Puerto
Rico, Cuba, The Philippines and France.
There were four Liberty Bond drives that by the
end of the war had raised more than $17 million,
and that was just an unheard-of
figure at the time.
And here's an extraordinary statistic, out of
an estimated 24 million households at the time,
some 20 million individuals
bought Liberty War Bonds.
This poster is a classic example of Pennell's
work, which typically combined a documentary
with a picturesque, but still friendly
based and eye witnessed observation.
His next in line, for the fourth Liberty-Loan
poster was an entirely different animal
and a real departure for Pennell.
It depicts a horrific scene with the Statue
of Liberty in ruins and New York City
in flames while under attack by enemy planes.
His idea was to show, "New York City bombed,
shot down, burning, blown up by an enemy.
A fleet of airplanes fly over lower Manhattan,
flames and smoke envelope
the burning skyscrapers.
In the foreground, Liberty from
a pile of ruins rises headless
on her pedestal, her torch shattered."
So, it's a little difficult to see the
planes unless you're in the presence
of the original drawing, though they
are clearly visible in the print poster
and here are details from
both the drawing up top.
The planes in sort of faint
light-blue are marked by the blue arrow
and I hope you can see them, descending
down diagonally toward the left.
The poster detailed below,
they are much clearer.
Within the conflagration, other details emerge
including a submarine heading toward the city
skyline with a sagging bridge in the distance
and poor Liberty's disembodied head nearby.
We also see sunken or sinking ships with the
American flag beginning to go underwater.
The lower margin of the drawing shows Pennell's
title and signature, indicates his dual role
as draftsman and printmaker and is annotated
in his hand watercolor sketch of idea.
But the actual spark came earlier.
Pennell gave a detailed account of the project
in his 1918 book called Joseph
Pennell's Liberty-Loan Poster,
and in it he describes making the initial
sketch pictured on the left as reproduced
from this book while riding the
train back from a New York meeting
of the Committee on Public Information.
And you can see he's laid in some
color indications like red in the sky.
Once he arrived home in Philadelphia, Pennell
made another drawing, which he then worked
up into a lithographic print and this is
the image that you see here on the right.
And Pennell wrote that this is the design he
submitted successfully for jury selection.
News coverage of the time reported that
Pennell's was one of 10 artist designs chosen
and that 10 million posters
would be printed all together.
Over 500,000 copies were to be
made of Pennell's poster alone.
The Library's collection includes some 30
examples of Pennell's working materials
for the poster and so far, that initial train
sketch on the left, which I've reproduced
from the book I mentioned, has
not been located in a collection.
I'm holding out hope and if anyone
runs across it, please let us know.
We do have the drawing and resulting
lithograph shown on the right.
We also have this sketchbook.
It's small, it's a little sketchbook in
which Pennell is apparently trying out titles
and the wording he later settled on was,
his idea was to say, now remember the scene
of conflagration, "Buy Liberty
Bonds or you will see this."
So, this was later softened
to a more poetic alternative
for the printed color poster, as we'll see.
Based on the available evidence and in
studying the original artworks themselves,
the sequence starts in black and
white with the train sketch first,
followed by the worked-up drawing and
lithograph and then on to full color.
On the far left is a proof of
the black and white lithograph
with lavish watercolor added by hand.
It looks like a drawing almost.
Next is Pennell's full-scale watercolor
drawing for which the title differed somewhat
from the final posters so, "Lest Liberty
Parish From The Face Of The Earth," became,
"That Liberty Shall Not Parish
From the Earth, Buy Liberty Bonds."
Furthermore, and far less well known,
Pennell explored a similar concept
in his second drawing dated July 4, 1918, which
moves the venue from New York to Philadelphia.
The drawings are a comparable
size and made in similar style
and color palate, and similar media.
The violence in my eyes is intensified by
adding a terrified crowd running in front
of Independence Hall and a prone
figure bleeding in the foreground.
I've not found much in the way of discussion
or explanation for this Philadelphia version,
but both drawings are listed in the unpublished
Catalogue Raisonne of Pennell's drawings
and paintings by Louis A. Wuerth, under
the heading, "War Poster Drawings."
As I've mentioned, these phantasmagorical
images were extremely unusable for Pennell,
very specific to their purpose in time.
There is a well-known story about a
meeting of the National Arts Club in 1920,
not long after the war, during
which Pennell took artist,
George Bellows to task on
the issue of authenticity.
He singled out Bellows amid showing the
execution of British Red Cross nurse,
Edith Cavell, who helped allied
prisoners escape during the war,
saying that the work would be much
more compelling and truly authentic
if Bellows had seen the event with his own eyes.
Bellows rejoinder was that it was true, he had
not seen the event, but nor, as far as he knew,
had Leonardo been present at the Last Supper.
On screen is Bellow's dramatic lithograph
and he also made a large-scale painting
which envisions an angelic Edith Cavell
descending a staircase while a firing squad
waits in the shadows below
at the lower right corner.
And of course, this argument, Pennell's
argument becomes somewhat ironic in light
of the Liberty Bond poster
designs we have been looking at.
But there is certainly an anomaly
in Pennell's broader body of work.
Right up until his death in 1926, Pennell
continued making prints and drawings based
on eye witness observation and
reflecting a changing world.
During this late period, he made a
series of beautiful watercolor drawings,
you saw this one earlier and it's
another one of my very favorites.
But he made hundreds of them and
they're incredibly beautiful.
He seems to have been making
them really for his own pleasure.
And they're capturing, many of them,
the changing light, weather and activity
on the East River, which he could see
from his Brooklyn apartment high point.
And as the Bellows' story suggests,
I think it must be said that anyone
who said he's Pennell [inaudible] will bump
up against his notoriously argumentative,
difficult and sometimes [inaudible] nature.
And this was remarkable enough that
it is mentioned in his obituaries,
along with long lists of honors and
achievements including his tireless, passionate,
constant advocacy of art and artists.
Pennell really gave his life to this and he left
his entire estate to the Library of Congress.
So, we have an extraordinary opportunity
to study a virtually complete collection
of his lithographs and etchings, about 1,900
altogether, about 4,000 of his drawings,
his publications and papers, along with
his wife's, their substantial collection
of James McNeill Whistler
art papers and [inaudible]
and Elizabeth Robbins Pennell's rare cookbook
collection and we also have the Pennell library.
And as we've seen, Pennell's artwork reflects
how he moved through history and art history
in ways that uniquely reflect the first
World War, as well as the construction
of the Panama Canal, the rise of
American cities and other key subjects.
So, we would like to leave you with some
resources beginning with the exhibition website
for our current show, Echoes of the Great War,
and also the art centric exhibition I
recently co-curated with my colleagues,
Sara Duke and Betsy Nahum-Miller,
it's called, World War I -
American Artists View the Great War.
All of the exhibits, texts and images are online
via the link screen, www.loc.gov/exhibits.
And here's.
Oh, I'm skipping ahead.
You can also explore over 1,900 digitized
World War I posters, as we mentioned,
in our online catalog at this direct link.
And of course, in person
in the Library of Congress,
Prints and Photographs Division reading room.
Here's a select bibliography of resources
including Creel's book about the Committee
on Public Information which I found
very valuable during World War I,
and some key resources for studying
Pennell on his prints and drawings,
which are also searchable in the Library's
online catalog at www.loc.gov/pictures,
and available for study, of
course, in our reading room,
along with over 76,000 photographs, prints,
and drawings related to World War I.
You can also send us reference questions
at this ask a librarian link on screen.
So, thank you so much for joining
us today, and I'll hand things back
to Naomi before we take questions.
>> Great, thanks so much Katherine,
really beautiful and fascinating work.
We'd love to have you guys share some questions
that Katherine can answer if you have them,
but before, well while we wait for your
questions, I have one myself, which is, so,
you mentioned that Pennell offered
the Library his entire estate,
can you talk more about his
relationship with the Library of Congress
and why did he choose to
have his work kept here?
>> So, our best clue comes from his wife's
biography of her husband, The Life and Letters
of Joseph Pennell, and it turns out that their
estate was headed to the New York Public Library
which also is a very wonderful home.
But according to Elizabeth Robbins Pennell,
after seeing the Library's print room,
Pennell decided he considered it the finest
anywhere, this is Pennell, the finest anywhere,
and still somewhat in need of
more fine print, so he saw a need
and around 1917 he made a new will in
favor of the Library and she wrote that,
according to his wife, Pennell
liked the idea of placing his legacy
in the Nation's Capital and
in the National Institution.
So, that's the short answer.
>> Thanks.
Again, let us know if you have questions, but
I'll ask one more, which is that, you know,
could you talk a little bit more
about the Liberty Bond Drive,
I'm not sure if you shared the
statistic that you and I talked about,
about the number of households in the
U.S. as compared to how many participated
in the bond drive, but if you haven't, it'd
be great to say or to reiterate if you did,
and then also tell us a little bit
more about that, about the drive?
>> Well so, let me just sort of give the
basic sort of definition, which is that,
so they were essentially,
so by buying a war bond,
it meant that you were essentially loaning money
to the U.S. Government in support of the war,
with the funds to be returned at a later
date, and this was framed as a patriotic duty
for every citizen from children to
millionaires, everyone was expected to step up.
The bonds were sold in denominations going
as low as $50, and you could also buy stamps
for just $.25 and buyers were given buttons,
sort of, I think of them sort of like our
"I voted" stickers today, to show
participation and encourage others to join in.
And let's see, the program was initiated
by Treasury Secretary William McAdoo,
and the bonds were promoted by major
celebrities of the day, like Charlie Chaplin
and Mary Pickford, and that
statistic is really incredible.
So, altogether they had raised more than $17
million for the Liberty Bond drive by the end
of the war, and out of it, an estimated
24 million households at that time,
some 20 million individuals bought Liberty
War Bonds, so wildly successful campaign.
>> Alright, thank you.
So, I haven't seen any other questions, so
I guess we'll close out today's session.
I do want to remind everyone
that this is part of the series.
There will be one more of
these webinars on World War I.
Oh, we do have a question, from Tim Garrity.
So, he says, how does Pennell's work compare
with the work of other World War I era artists
in other nations like Britain,
Germany, France and Russia?
Are there major differences?
>> So, I think that you can compare Pennell's
work to a British artist like Muirhead Bone.
I think his work is sort of
representative, picturesque,
something that had fellow comparisons in
Europe and certainly in England, and of course,
although he felt very much an
American, he spent a lot of time
in Britain, was also an anglophile.
So, I can mention a few of the British artists,
I mentioned Muirhead Bone, James McBey,
and also an extremely influential artist
who worked with the British government,
Dutch artist, Louis Raemaekers, whose
images illustrated the Bryce report,
of reported German atrocities.
So, that's a great question.
I could go on, but that's an essential answer.
>> OK great.
So, another question, this is from Ruth.
She says, you pointed to the
departure from Pennell's typical style
that left Liberty parish departure from his
typical style, so can you talk a little bit more
about why he made that departure?
>> So, I would love to know why, and
I've looked for clues in his letters
and I've looked for, I mean, I don't know why.
I think that he was responding
to something very specific, very,
if I'm allowed to conjecture a little bit,
I think a lot about this sort of tension
between his being a pacifist and his being so
engaged and compelled by the technology of war,
I know he was distressed, disturbed, you know,
so he just chose a very, what's the word I want,
I don't, histrionic isn't the word
I groping for, but it's an extreme,
it's an extreme response, and there are
other comparable posters in our collection,
on that very first slide that I showed, there's
a poster by John Norton, "Keep these off USA",
which shows a bloody German soldier boot.
So, it's one, it's one, it's a tone that's used
by more than one artist, to sort of show the,
show how vital it was to be engaged in these
Liberty-Loan bond drives in no uncertain terms.
>> Alright, well one last comment
that may lead to a question, actually.
So, Jerry said that the poster depicting the
young woman in the Navy uniform was still in use
by the Navy when I was in
the service in the 70's.
>> Oh wow.
>> Which is interesting, but it also makes
me wonder if you might speak a little bit
about the legacy either of some of the images to
come out of the Committee on Public Information
in World War I or just a bit about the growth
of marketing after the war as a result,
what's the legacy of these
images and effort around them?
>> So, there's a really great example to
sort of site in answering that question.
James Montgomery Flagg's Uncle Sam, I want
you for the U.S. Army, was repurposed.
It was so powerful it was repurposed
during World War II and if you go
to our online catalog you can
see the different versions,
and one of them also includes a portrait
of FDR, Franklin Delano Roosevelt.
So, I think what happened was the World War I
posters, the division of pictorial publicity,
this extraordinary phenomenon which was even
considered by artists and critics at the time,
there was a self-awareness that
something special was going on,
that something new was happening and that
they were moving the equation forward
and opening the door, and I think it was
one in a series of information revolutions.
I think you could look at it that way, that
really things were moved forward in a way
that opened the door for the future.
>> Alright, well thanks for that, and
thank you for this wonderful presentation.
So, I'll wrap up with a few notes.
One is that, as I was saying
earlier, this is part of a series,
and so we'll have one more webinar that
will be on December 12 at 2:00 eastern.
The exhibition co-curator, Ryan Reft
of the Manuscript Division will discuss
Charles Hamilton Houston's wartime service,
and experiences as a young officer serving
in a segregated military, and the influences
of those experiences on his later work in
civil rights including as the chief attorney
for the NAACP and a mentor to Thurgood Marshall.
This also was previously a gallery talk
and like Katherine's, a wonderful one,
so I hope you'll join us for
the last of our webinar series.
Today, as you may know, is Giving Tuesday, so
in that spirit, I'd like to just share that some
of our programs here are made possible by
donations and gifts from generous citizens,
so the Library of Congress has introduced
a new initiative that is called,
"To Spark a Lifelong Adventure of Learning."
If you'd like to learn more or support
this effort, you can go to loc.gov/donate.
And finally, we'd love to know what
you thought of today's session.
If you can share your comments on the
survey, we'd very much appreciate it.
And, if you have a question, oh, thank you.
We appreciate your participation in the webinar
today, and again you'll find the recording
on the World War I Exhibition website
and also the Library's YouTube channel
once it has been properly captioned,
which should be in a few weeks.
So, thank you all so much for participating.
>> Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.